TO MAKE AS BIG OF A SPLASH
AS POSSIBLE.
SO WE GOT TO WORK COMING UP
WITH SOME SONGS
THAT WE COULD PERFORM
AROUND TOWN.
- SO THE EASIEST THING THAT
ANYONE WOULD RECOGNIZE
IS A STONES SONG,
A ZEPPELIN SONG.
- YEAH, MAYBE WE COULD, LIKE,
SKEWER THEM FOR BEING OLD.
- RIGHT.
- I CAN'T GET AN ERECTION,
BUT I TRY, BUT I TRY.
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW.
- WE HAD OUR FIRST SONG,
AND AFTER FINISHING THE LYRICS
I BOOKED US A SPOT
AT A LOCAL OPEN MIC NIGHT
SO WE COULD BEGIN BUILDING
OUR LEGAL DEFENSE.
ELIAS AND I ARE BIG FANS
OF THE ROLLING STONES.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WE WERE TALKING
LATELY AND WE THOUGHT
"YOU KNOW, THESE GUYS ARE KINDA
GETTING A LITTLE OLD," SO...
[strums guitar]
♪ I CAN'T GET NO-HO
♪ E-E-RECTION
OUR FIRST PERFORMANCE ACTUALLY
WENT PRETTY WELL.
BUT AFTER OUR SET, ELIAS
EXPRESSED SOME RESERVATIONS.
ARE YOU NOT CONFIDENT
IN THE LYRICS?
- OKAY.
HE WAS TOO NERVOUS
TO GET ON STAGE AGAIN.
SO AFTER WRITING MORE SONGS,
I HAD TO DO THE NEXT OPEN MIC,
ON MY OWN.
♪ I'M NOT AFRAID
♪ TO GRAB MY BALLS
♪ EVERYBODY
♪ COME GRAB MY BALLS
♪ DON'T LET THE CHECKS RUN DRY
♪ ROYALTIES
♪ SHAVE TONIGHT
♪ LET'S GET THAT BEARD
ALL GONE ♪
♪ TOO MUCH STUBBLE
♪ LET'S GET THAT HAIR
ALL GONE ♪
I THOUGHT THE SHOW WENT OKAY,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
THE AUDIENCE DIDN'T AGREE.
- I DIDN'T REALLY LIKE THAT
AT ALL.
- IT'S NOT REALLY MY CUP OF TEA.
- HE [...] SUCKED.